this week the global gaming expo showing
off the newest games and gadgets to
entice you to hit the casino floor
victoria saha well she's already there
she's the venetian expo center this
morning with a look at the future
victoria the future good morning
oh man guys we we are having so much fun
here i was um taking a shot at this but
i'm gonna show you how it works this is
part of sports betting it's part of the
experience i might make a fool of myself
on live tv but it's okay right
i'm going to have you hold this all
right
so joining me now is
jordan 11 with scientific games tell us
the thrill behind sports betting
absolutely thrilled sports betting's it
puts you in the game as a as a better
you're watching the game you get all the
action you're able to place a bet you're
able to experience the ups and downs of
not only the game but also you know
winning and losing money making side
bets have having fun with friends it
really just enhances the experience of
the game all right so let's walk on over
here can you give us an overview of how
it works
across here
yeah so so we have a couple of different
experiences victoria so this this is one
of our kiosks this you would find in us
in an actual physical sports book you
would walk up you'd be able to place
your money in here or your if you have
carded play be able to place your card
in here you make your selection from all
these different games you can see these
are all a bunch of pre-match
options spread and the money line
all the different sports up here when
the game is actually happening you can
make bets their calls are called in play
bets that sort of say like hey what's
going to happen this quarter or how many
yards is tom brady going to pass for and
then you get your little bet slip then
you if you lose you throw it away if you
win you walk up back to the kiosk redeem
your money or back up to the desk and
redeem your money that way too and you
don't have to be in a casino to take
part right exactly you don't have to be
a casino to take part so this is the
same experience even more enhanced on a
mobile device so here you have all the
same things that i described and more
imagine that you're sitting in a
physical sports book or at home with
your friends or on a train somewhere and
you're able to
go ahead and place all the same types of
bets that we just talked to scroll
between different options you're logged
in with your account you can get loyalty
points it really really supersizes the
experience and makes it exciting and we
at scientific games and openvet we power
all the technology and the content that
goes into that so that the books can run
online and in the retail experience for
their customers
thanks such a fun time all right john
and heather i'm going to send it back to
you guys
she's got skills yeah i was going to say
the las vegas aces are back in action
tonight i think is their next game is an
elimination game victoria i think they
could might be able to use you as their
new point yeah she's all warmed up and
ready to go yeah thanks victoria
appreciate that